it's even crazier than that it's a
sermon
in a chapel by the chaplain in the
christian school
how did we get this far
[Music]
as the state established church of
secular progressivism
enforces its orthodoxies more and more
each day
in the united states in britain
throughout the west
i am so pleased to be able to speak
today with a heretic
someone who has questioned the the
dominant
liberal regime and it's deeply
intolerant
ideology of tolerance that person would
be the reverend dr
bernard randall who was until very
recently chaplain at trent
college former chaplain at cambridge
university graduate
of oxford university but we will not
hold those sorts of things
against him dr randall thank you so much
for being here
it's my pleasure absolutely delighted to
talk to you today
i cannot say that i was surprised when i
saw what happened to you
i was outraged i was horrified i was
deeply saddened for the state of the
anglosphere in the world
but i was not surprised that you were
punished you were fired from your
position as
chaplain you were reported to a terror
watch list
because you sort of
kind of defended the legitimacy of being
a christian in the modern world
yeah i mean it surprised me quite how
badly people took it i i think i would
be fair to say you know i was doing my
job
christian chaplin in a christian school
and
just trying to present the fact that you
know christian beliefs do vary
from some of this political uh agenda
identity politics kind of stuff um
and that you're allowed to believe the
christian beliefs that's all i was
saying
um along with where we have
disagreements respect one another
and i said respect one another about
half a dozen times in the space of sort
a 10-minute
sermon that was the most important
takeaway
really but for daring to say yes you may
believe the church is teaching on
marriage you may believe
that biological sex is real and
sometimes makes a difference
uh you may question whether this will be
gender identity stuff is really coherent
does it make sense and if it doesn't
make sense
look at other ways of understanding
these things for daring to say that
i was yeah hauled over the coals
absolutely so you were you were fired
from your job presumably because you
were at a radical
leftist college that that has no truck
with with christian ideas is that right
uh no the foundation of the the school
uh is uh according to the protestant and
evangelical principles of the church of
england
so the church as established by law
in in britain in england um and
yeah on on paper i was doing exactly
what i was supposed to do my contract
said you will uphold and support
the stated aims and purposes of the
school i did that
yeah certain people didn't like it
this happens in the united states as
well putatively christian institutions
have been hollowed out by cultural
revolutionaries and so now
if you espouse christian orthodoxy or
anything even vaguely resembling
christian orthodoxy
you'll be punished for it how did that
happen
to your former college
in fairness i don't know quite how it
got to the stage it got to i suppose i
mean
britain is is a secular in many ways as
as the us
i'm sure and because it's a fee paying
school
i guess the the management the
leadership thought
we need to move in the direction of our
customers um
rather than being true to the christian
foundation and saying actually we have
something to offer
which is really valuable and we'd like
to carry on offering it understanding
that not everyone in the school is
christian
and indeed there were pupils of other
faiths uh and atheists and and so on um
so as a christian chaplain speaking to
that audience everything i say is kind
of controversial you know just to say
god exists
he's controversial to some of them
didn't think i was doing anything
much more controversial than that in
fairness maybe ruffle a few feathers
fine okay
that's that's kind of the job of a
minister isn't it i think
um but no that was that was not to be
done
yes i thought it's the job of the
christian and the the job of the
shepherds to become very very worldly
and win
all the sorts of applause no maybe not i
think it might be the opposite of that i
want to get to the substance of your
lecture in a moment but am i correct
in what i understand that you were not
only fired but you were reported
to the anti-terrorism agency of the
united kingdom
um that's right in in the uk we have
this thing called
prevent which is uh to prevent extremism
and so anybody who's a danger of being a
terrorist or
radicalizing others can be reported to
the police
with a special prevent unit um and there
are units across the country
and um i was reported to them and and
fortunately it didn't go very far um the
the unit the police said no this doesn't
meet the threshold
for a terrorist which i think is no
great surprise
um but the police officer did say this
is wholly inappropriate in a school and
wholly inappropriate in
society which says something about the
state of
the capture of the police by this sort
of ideology as well unfortunately in
this country
i'm glad that that you got off the hook
for your outrageous crime but but
it does raise this question what will
happen next time what will happen in a
few years or
who know at this rate even in a few
months i want to get into the the
lecture itself
the lecture was called competing
ideologies
this does not sound particularly uh
provocative
or violent as far as i can tell
what what's the thesis what's what's
what got you into so much trouble
well well to start with it it's not a
lecture it's actually a sermon
it's an act of worship of christian
worship in a christian chapel in a
christian school
led by a christian minister no great
surprises
but i might say some christian friendly
things
i thought um but there we go so the
thesis
was basically in many areas of life
people have different sets of ideas
ideologies
and i used the example of brexit some
people wanted to leave the european
union in this country some people wanted
to remain
some were more interested in the sort of
democratic rights of
a sovereign nation some people more
interested in the economics
and you know making sure that jobs were
preserved and there were two sides to
that argument
and it's not as if one is right and one
is wrong it's just different ways of
looking at the same thing
so i started with that argument that
sort of example
and said and actually when it comes to
some of these lgbt
areas although there are areas of
agreement
no one should be discriminated against
for who they are you know love your
neighbor as yourself
is absolutely crucial um nevertheless
there are disagreements such as on
marriage on
biology and the way we talk about gender
identity
and you're free to make up your own mind
you can hear someone out and go
no that's not for me and this was
prompted by a pupil at school
saying to me how come we're told in a
christian school we
have to accept all this lgbt stuff
have to accept and and that was the
thing that really struck me about that
question
that people you know wanted to know
what's going on here what can we do what
can we
believe well i i wonder too if if
someone in a madrassa would be told that
they have to accept the lgbt stuff it
seems to me
perhaps i'm speaking out of turn that
there is a bit of a double standard here
where the christians are held to a
different standard
than than other religious people
i think that's absolutely right
christians are supposed to be kind and
tolerant
and you know love your neighbor sounds
as if
you don't want to ever possibly upset
your neighbor but of course it doesn't
necessarily work that way jesus was
willing to upset people
from time to time seem to remember
something about blasphemy and nailing
him to a cross
i may be misremembering that possibly
but you know so
it's it's a wide secular
misunderstanding of what
christianity is about i think they think
it's just you know be nice
that'll do um there's a lot more to it
it's got a deeper heart and a deeper a
mind
than that um which perhaps they didn't
want to hear about
they just thought oh just tell the kids
be nice to each other and that's enough
it reminds me of that famous line i
think it's from niebuhr
you can correct me if i'm wrong who said
that uh so much of
of the modern understanding of
christianity is that uh god without
wrath leads a people without sin
to a kingdom without judgment through
the ministrations of a christ without a
cross
which is not much of a faith left
absolutely i mean you you actually have
to remind people there is a call to
christianity that isn't the same
as any other faith and you know at the
start
of every school year one of my first
chapel services i would say you know i
am unapologetically christian
it's a christian school this is the sort
of foundation that we try to
run ourselves by but the fact that i
don't apologize for being christian
means you don't have to apologize if you
are muslim
or hindu or atheist or whatever you do
your
faith position properly sensibly
thoroughly and i'll do mine thoroughly
and and that's you know no one is
neutral
no one doesn't have a viewpoint
but together we rub up and and work
through these disagreements and
and well that's how it should work but
apparently not well this
of course gets to the the question that
is bedeviling all of us in the west
today which is
that of tolerance and free speech and
what the radical left seems to be saying
is that we cannot tolerate intolerance
and in a way
their argument is reminiscent of that
line from chesterton who says there is a
thought that stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped and the left is now saying
no uh dr randall you you are
a preaching intolerance and therefore we
cannot tolerate you but i just
wonder if if let's say
it is now unacceptable to question any
aspect of the lgbt ideology
because you will offend somebody who
participates in that
what happens if a muslim person quotes
the quran
if a muslim person quotes the quran
which says not merely to condemn someone
who engages in that sort of behavior but
actually calls for violence against
people
who engage in that sort of behavior is
the is the muslim person
victimizing the lgbt person on the basis
of his identity
is the is the lgbt guy victimizing the
muslim on the basis of his
religious identity where does this end
how can we
tolerate one another in this in this
framework
i mean that's the sort of big question
isn't it i mean it should be that
well either someone has to give
completely or actually ideally both
sides are all different opinions give a
bit and there's this space in the middle
where we can agree to differ
we know that some of the things we say
might be a bit offensive
to others but we live with that because
that's the way that free speech
has to work i think what we mustn't have
and what we seem to have developed is
this sense that some people's feelings
are more important
than others and that's you know some
people are more valuable than others
that's certain you know christian
value um but that's the way it seems to
happen so when
um kids in the school were being taught
about this stuff one of the sessions
talked about
how can we be a more lgbt plus friendly
school
that's okay i guess what are the
obstacles to being lgbt
plus friendly and then if a pupil is
sitting there thinking well i'm
i'm a traditional christian i'm a muslim
or whatever and i'm not totally happy
with this
am i the obstacle right to being lgbt
friendly and and how can we be lgbt
allies that's one of the questions they
were asked to
explore well if if we're being allies
but then that makes the enemy
am i the enemy because i'm not
completely happy with this
and and how deeply hurt is a person who
thinks they're an obstacle and an
enemy of what the school is trying to do
and yet
that people's feelings matter not one
little bit
compared to we mustn't hurt the feelings
of lgbt
pupils and that's not a sustainable
position
for a community to be in well that's
such a good point i hadn't considered
it that the feeling of the christian
student at the christian school
who is told that he is a bigot who is
told that he's hateful
because he holds a very traditional
understanding of human nature i mean
even if you take the lbg
of it aside for a moment even just on
this issue of the t of transgenderism
if you believe that your body has
anything at all to do with who you
really are
if you know perhaps you hold the
traditional christian understanding that
we're body and soul together we're not
not just one or the other
now you're told that you're a hateful
bigot and you're no longer accepted even
at a christian school
yeah absolutely right and you can you
can understand that gender dysphoria is
a real thing and there are people who
really suffer terribly
and for them sometimes that the least
bad option is
is transition and medical treatments and
that's not a happy thing for anyone to
go through it's not easy
you can believe in that and be okay with
that but
not necessarily believe that there's
this thing called a gender identity
which is sort of
some kind of soul inside which is a male
identity or a female identity or a
whatever these other things are and i
would say people are free to describe
themselves that way if they want
but don't make everybody else have to go
along with
your belief system it's kind of like if
i was talking to a muslim
um who was very fervent and whenever he
mentioned muhammad
would say peace be upon him which a lot
of muslims do and that's fine if that's
what you want to do
but if that muslim then says to me if
you're ever going to talk to me you must
say
muhammad peace be upon him that's asking
me to
partake in his belief system and and i
shouldn't have to do that
right i might as a courtesy but i
shouldn't have to and that's that's
the problem that we have here right you
know i i actually noticed you're
reminding me of this
some years ago when muhammad was in the
news quite a lot
there was this tendency even in the west
to to refer to him as the prophet
muhammad
and i thought well it doesn't really
bother me if muslims call him the
prophet muhammad but
i certainly don't consider him a prophet
and i'm not going to call him such
and you really really ought to make me
do that and you know any more than i
would
i would uh try to change your speech on
a topic like that
yeah i think that's absolutely right and
if you start saying
the prophet muhammad uh or you feel you
have to say that
that's making a claim about him and then
it's only a very short step to
muslims saying oh well why can't you
just say the prophet jesus
and when you start to take the steps
forward in the discussion
you realize where it could end up and
actually you need to be able to say
surely you know liberal tolerance is
you have your own beliefs and you're
allowed to stick with them
respecting other people you don't use
slurs or whatever but to say
muhammad he's a million miles from a
slur as far as i can tell
of course coincidentally uh dr randall i
i have a book on this topic of speech
sort of how we got to this point
i have it coming out next month it's
called speechless i notice you have many
probably more worthwhile books behind
you in your in your office but i'll have
to send you a copy
in any case because i do fear that this
ideology is
it's really just running only in this
one direction so i have to ask you
are we going to fight back and i'm using
the we a little liberally here
are you going to fight back against this
injustice that has been done to you
i am fighting back i am taking the
school to court
to uh claim for discrimination and
unfair dismissal
um and we'll see what comes of that and
i'm i'm really pleased actually that
this story has has
got a lot of attention in the uk but
also you know
across the world yourselves obviously um
and and it's it's because of the
extremeness
of saying this guy should be reported as
a potential terror threat
um it's allowed people to see just how
far the people
who buy into this uh identity politics
how just how far they might be willing
to go um
and and i didn't get arrested this time
but how
soon before someone is arrested for
something as as innocuous as what i said
unless now we stop and we say
no no further we must actually stand up
for just real tolerance not the
the pseudo tolerance um that the
identity politics people
uh seem to talk about too much you're
right and of course you know
i suppose throwing back this argument if
we can't tolerate intolerance that you
hear so often from the left
you might go back to chesterton's
observation that there's a thought that
stops thought and it's the only thought
that ought to be stopped
our understanding of tolerance in our
civilization
derives from christianity if you abuse
this tolerance
to chase christianity out of a christian
school
in a christian country goodness gracious
you've undermined the whole system
yeah absolutely right i think well one
of the things is that this sort of
identity politics has a lot to do with
post-modernism which doesn't believe
there's any truth
um whereas christianity says there is
truth you know jesus says i am the way
the truth and the life he doesn't say i
am the opinion the feelings and the
lived experience or something whatever
it might be that's that's not
what christians believe and and yes the
christians truth matters truth exists
and um you can also talk about jesus
being the logos
of god the word the reason the logic the
thinking about it
of god and if we don't think about it
how are we going to get to the truth
and if we want the truth we have to
think about it to get there and that
that all goes together with these
core liberal values which are yes they
are founded in the judeo-christian
tradition they're not found anywhere
else uh
in the world's history as far as i can
tell so dr randall where can people
support you you know get updates on the
case support support your legal defense
the case that you're bringing now
against this school well i'm being
supported by a really great organization
called
christian concern here in the uk um and
they
are providing the lawyers for me uh
which
unfortunately doesn't come cheap but
they are they are working pro bono and
if
this wasn't for the public good i don't
know what is um
so you can see more about me um on their
webpage
christianconcerned.com bernard
so easy enough to remember i hope um and
there's a
lot more information there's the text
and my sermon is on there
and there is a donate button as well if
anybody is willing and able
uh to help us fight this really i think
very important fighter this time
well i look forward to to hearing the
whole sermon because i you know as i'd
seen a clip of it
and i have seen some news coverage on it
but actually
my understanding was that it was it was
just a typical university lecture
but it's even crazier than that it's a
sermon
in a chapel by the chaplain in the
christian school
how did we get this far i would i would
highly recommend that people head on
over to christian concern
uh follow dr randall uh and also
support this legal effort because it's
it's about
it's about a whole lot more than just
you dr randall this this would seem
to me to be really what what the whole
fight is about here to maintain any
semblance of our culture
and the things that we cherish in our
civilization
i i totally agree i think you know this
is this is one of those points where
if you don't stand up and be counted if
you don't draw the line in the sand
whatever metaphor you want to use you
know
not now when right you always hear about
michael is this the hill you want to die
on and i say look i don't intend to die
on any hills but
the reason that one might consider dying
on a hill is because eventually you run
out of hills and
eventually you've just lost the whole
battle so absolutely uh we must take a
stand here
dr bernard randall sorry that this has
happened to you but in a sense
i suppose it's a bit of a felix culpa
you know it's a kind of a happy thing
because this is a
this could be a real moment when we when
we stop this momentum
and start pushing back to reclaim our
culture i
really hope so and then it will have
been worth it for all the hardship and
the pain that it's caused yeah dr
bernard randall thank you so much for
being here
my pleasure thank you
you